well it takes a lot of time to plan a
wedding you probably know that if you're
a bride and groom getting ready for the
big event the bridal spectacular wedding
Expo is returning to Las Vegas this
weekend it's the 63rd Expo over at the
Rio attracting brides and grooms and
they're nervous you've got to plan
photographers getting a dress getting a
venue in Candace Charles joins us live
right now with all of the great stuff
you can find in that one place at the
Rio and it's for a good cause too what's
that all about Candace
Sherry honestly you made me a little
nervous with the list as well so I can't
imagine that folks are nervous when
they're trying to plan a wedding good
morning to you good morning folks but
you know what the Bible spectacular
wedding Expo has you covered with dozens
of vendors many of them right here in
Vegas I have vital spectaculars uh Laura
Covington with me now thank you so much
for joining us tell us where our folks
coming from how many attendees you guys
expect to be here and what's new this
year Well we you know the most of our
brides are coming from right here in Las
Vegas we have a passion for helping Las
Vegas Brides plan their dream weddings
and we do we're going to have over a
hundred vendors here to help them
because like your friend said you know
it is a huge planning wedding there's so
many steps so many vendors involved and
we want to get everybody in one place in
one day where they can meet them all get
all their needs fulfill all those
wedding dreams and that's right here at
the bridal spectacular that's awesome
okay so what's new this year and what's
trending I see this has a little bit of
black yeah so black on the wedding dress
is huge right now ridiculously huge we
have four dresses with black in them in
our fashion show and I was like this is
clearly the thing so sure enough it's
all over Tick Tock you can't they can't
get enough of it whether the dress is
all black or black on nude or like this
where you still have that classic white
wedding dress but with hints of black
these dresses from brilliant Bridal
definitely show off all those fun trends
that are going on awesome thank you so
much Laura we appreciate you and besides
it being about wedding dresses and
flowers they're also giving back to the
community they're partnering with
shining star community services so if
you have an item for a foster child toy
blanket or anything bring that with you
it all kicks off here tomorrow at date
night and of course they'll be having a
shop to you drop on Saturday the diamond
dive is back you'll get a chance to win
a 2500 engagement ring though to
participate can also when other
luxurious jewelry so we'll have all the
details for you on the website
atlasnow.com for now live from Maria I'm
Candace Charles 8 News Now